glad you could drop in bismillah
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
before we start hit that notification
bell after you subscribe
for nothing
or die for something now who doesn't
know our friend sir vester stallone
everybody should change
that one adrian
or how about when he went all out in
extreme and ramble i wanna go oh johnny
i wanna drive my chevy i don't know what
i can't find
someone shared this with me and i
thought good advice he's really on point
something extremely important
time
so let's listen to what sylvester
stallone has to say pay close attention
to this one word he's going to be using
time time what's it reminds you of let
me know in the comments below
what do you think
is the most valuable thing you might
have in your life that you really don't
pay attention to especially when you're
young because you just feel
you have an abundance of it
it's never ending
time
what came to your mind when you heard
this word time if you connect it to the
quran go ahead and share with me in the
comments below and i'll share with you
what came to my mind
and i'll elaborate some more now go
ahead sylvester stallone and tell us
some more
time and as you get older you realize
time becomes
your currency subhanallah he said time
becomes your currency how many out there
are just wasting time via the instagram
twitter tick tock facebook social media
just prattling about insignificant
things you name it if you accumulate
just think about that if you accumulate
add it up day by day each day not to
mention the weeks months and years
how much of it actually is beneficial
time
versus useless time think about that
it's very deep
things you'll get good deeds or bad
deeds for and ask yourself which one
when i'm doing all these things is
writing the angel on the left or the one
on the right let's hear what else
sylvester stallone has to say when you
realize there's less runway up ahead
than behind
you sometimes learned that too late he
said when you realize there is less
runway up ahead than behind you
sometimes you learn too late
this is deep brothers and sisters
and sylvester stallone the muslims will
appreciate this as we take these kind of
topics seriously
as you're referring to our dd departure
date as islam has so many things to say
about this topic and it behooves you
sylvester
to look into and see for yourself now if
you didn't know islam simply means to
submit your will to the creator of the
heavens and earth and we invite you to
it my friend so i'm telling you people
that
you really have to be very very very
stingy with your time
don't waste it on people that
aren't like-minded
he says don't waste your time with
unlike-minded people don't waste it
doing things that you know
are not
part of your dream plan
don't
waste time being bitter which i know
i've been argumentative
i understand the meaning of hate because
in the end
it's just waste your most valuable asset
time
so what can we take from this if you
come across people and they're trying to
invite you
to the club still going to the club
don't waste my
time people who are still partying and
playing those tracks that put you in the
la la land tell them don't waste my
time
friends who are inviting you to get back
to getting pimped by shaytan to the
alcohol to the drinks to the party to
the drugs to the moral decay and
corruption things that corrupt the heart
mind body and soul tell them don't waste
my
time time to the kim kardashians and the
dj khaleds tell them i don't want to be
part of it don't waste my
time
or you got friends who remind you of
your true purpose in life your creator
when you mess up they remind you of the
hereafter they remind you of when it's
time for salah when it's time for prayer
or they're trying to get you out of
hijab into some tawdry dress tell him
don't waste my
time
time jenna's on my mind nothing is over
nothing now my brothers and sisters one
last chance what did that remind you of
when he was talking about time time
repeatedly go ahead leave that in the
comments below from the quran it makes
you think did sylvester stallone ever
read the quran yes i know
i just had no idea probably not and if
you did possibly a really bad
translation from much of the hate
machine that's out there inshallah this
video gets to him with your help do you
think he'll read the quran verbatim word
of god almighty yes
yes
make dua for his guidance and his fans
guidance inshallah those who will be
watching this video our guest glad you
could drop in now back to what i was
thinking here's the answer as soon as
sylvester stallone
started talking over and over about the
importance of time time
for those that know
it reminded me of the surah from the
quran where god almighty the creator is
saying in the name of god the gracious
the merciful
[Music]
by time
all mankind is in loss except those who
believe
and believe in what in the pure
monotheism it's called the tohi the pure
monotheism not the father son holy ghost
trinity no just one god and encourage
people and invite people to the truth
and recommend patience and perseverance
in this next clip
where sylvester stallone he's talking
about christ we'll get that to a second
i really never caught
that rocky was used
in this way to kind of proselytize
in this way he was they were doing this
he was doing his kind of his dawah
subhanallah people don't realize it's
the first shot is this shot of christ
and it comes down over the uh the beams
of the church now sir versus shalom you
talk about christ which means the
messiah
translated christ
did you know as muslims we love jesus
christ as one of the mightiest
messengers sent by god
in a chain of messengers let me just
name a few of the other mighty
messengers abraham
noah moses jesus and muhammad just lean
being the last and final messenger sent
to mankind it had to come to an end he
just happens to be the last to find a
messenger who is also sent as a mercy to
mankind for you so going back to jesus
we believe in his miracles
in his miraculous birth that he gave
life to the dead by god's permission he
healed the sick by god's permission by
god almighty allah's permission and
often you hear in church for those that
believe in jesus or if they deny jesus
we believe in him and we believe if you
deny jesus
as a mighty messenger if you deny him
that he was sent by the creator of the
heavens if you curse him like some
people do in his mother
that you can end up in the hell fire
and if you also take him as a god or a
literal son of god you can also end up
in that place too because this is very
important my friend and everybody out
there jesus never ever i know you hear
these things but not everything that we
hear is based on evidence and truth
jesus never ever claimed to be the god
the creator or literal son of god or did
he ever call people to worship himself
he only called people to worship the one
up above the creator of the heavens and
earth god almighty allah actually
find christian ideals that he finds love
he starts to bring people together in
this next clip sylvester stallone he was
talking he talks about
these slogans he finds loves brings
people together
that's why we call it the ummah this is
the community of almost 2 billion
muslims
and we ask you
to come come to visit us come to a
mosque go ahead and read the quran
and go ahead and connect with a muslim
so you can go ahead and learn more as
we're inviting you to this beautiful way
of life of submission to the creator not
the creation himself with old friends
even ex-fighters that read scripture and
then when he goes into the ring talk
about in that clip reading scripture
salon why not read the quran i heard
you've read i mean this is amazing
people read all sites of books and i've
heard that you've read all of
shakespeare's books
so why not read the quran as a potential
we know it's the verbatim word of god
almighty but why don't you as a
potential book from your creator to you
why don't you read it and i have a
surprise for you at the end and for all
your fans there is one thing about
speaking the word but eventually you do
need the crusader
someone who goes out there and and has
to defend it and face evil one-on-one
this is extremely interesting
you said sylvester stallone you said
there's one thing about speaking the
word meaning the word of god but
eventually you need a crusader one who
is has to face evil one-on-one these are
your words eventually you do need the
crusader
someone who goes out there and and has
to defend it and face evil so what you
said there is pretty much jihad
i mean they say sebastian has taught
they can they can actually take this and
say sylvester stallone is talking about
jihad this is where the law stops
and i start did you catch that because
jihad is to struggle and strive against
evil that's what you're talking about
one has to step up eventually from
speaking to go ahead and fight against
evil and that's a whole different topic
in and of itself but that's what jihad
means is to struggle and strive against
evil and corruption and again that's a
whole different topic we've done many
shows on this
just go to our channel and type in the
word jihad
and we go more in detail and you can
watch some of the programs
that discuss
this concept this term the subject jihad
you know i was very strict catholic and
then when i got to hollywood and all of
a sudden you're giving the key to the
candy stores and temptation abounds not
anybody else from this background or
like him i believe sir sloane is italian
i want you
and anyone else out there to check out
my brother michael de cerro michael de
chero
he was also raised a strict catholic
with over eight years in a monastery you
can hear where he's talking about
worshiping only one god hero israel the
lord your god is one god worship him
alone about jesus the trinity
if jesus was god or bringing something
new he should have said heroes or the
lord thy god is me or the lord thy god
is three or the lord thy god is three in
one
what happened and let me direct you that
if you go to our channel that's number
442
442 you can see the entire episode and
while i'm giving out numbers you can
also check out
8 37 where we talk about the different
miracles in the quran particularly this
one of the splitting of the moon check
that out yes
yes and special salon let me just share
one verse ayah from the quran since
we're talking about jesus where god
almighty allah is saying the messiah
son of mary was only a messenger before
whom other messengers had passed away
and his mother was a woman of truth they
both used to eat food
note how i make clear the revelations to
them and note how they are deluded this
is in chapter 5 verse 75 in the quran
verbatim word of god almighty think
about that my friend sylvester stallone
anyone who this is common sense anyone
who eats food can't be god cannot be
divine
they are not self-sufficient they are
dependent on the creator on god
they have to answer the call of nature
and if there's no toilet they have to
look for the rocks in the bush
now we don't want to go ahead and
tribute that to the crate that happens
on the earth god almighty god doesn't
look for the bush in the rocks he's
above all these things humans ascribe to
him that's why we say subhanallah glory
be to god the most high first i know
i just had no idea just a few
interesting points i mean as muslims we
love also moses and did you know that
moses is mentioned 136 times in the
quran why wouldn't you want to read the
quran to learn about what the quran says
about moses about abraham he was a pure
monotheist remember abraham wasn't a jew
or christian but he was one who
submitted his will to the creator to
heavens and earth to god almighty allah
he was a muslim because that's what a
muslim mean one who submits his or her
to the one god he's mentioned 69 times
in the quran noah he's also mentioned 43
times in the quran as a muslim a
submitter to god joseph yusuf he's
mentioned 27 times in the quran as one
who submitted his will to god look at
the chain of revelation all these
messengers came like lot of islam he's
mentioned 27 times in the quran and he's
also look at his story very interesting
look at the moral message that he's
calling to muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him he's mentioned four times
ton of references to him but just think
about it side note over here why would
he if he's writing this book why
wouldn't he elevate himself more in the
quran why would he elevate his own
mother instead he's elevating jesus's
mother because it's not him it's god
almighty and there's a whole chapter
named after his blessed mother media
mary
in the quran that's why you should read
the quran and this is a very interesting
point
jesus the son of mary is mentioned an
equal number of times as adam the first
man exactly 25 times each
so let me just get you one more
sylvester sylvester one more
and the rest you can read on your own
in chapter 3 59 of the quran
god almighty this is god almighty
speaking about jesus he said the
likeness of jesus in god's sight is that
of adam he created him from thus then he
said to him be and he was
so turn your thinking caps on
if anyone had more of a right
to be called the son of god it would be
adam as he had no mother or did he have
a father but in the language of that
time the language of the jews at that
time son of god meant someone who was
close to god a servant or a slave of god
not a
not a literal son of god you see cats
have kittens
cows have calves dogs have puppies so
what do you mean people don't think
when they say this what are you saying
when god had a son
a baby god no this does not benefit the
majesty of the creator god almighty this
does not befit
the supreme creator of the heavens and
earth these are pagan concepts as jesus
him himself his original followers his
companions his disciples
his brother james the earliest
christians they didn't ever preach teach
or taught any of these things they
taught and brought that pure monotheism
but over time the message got changed
and corrupted and distorted that's why
god almighty the creator allah sent the
quran
and we're inviting you sylvester
stallone and the people out there to go
ahead and read the quran and the
surprise is we're going to make this
easy you can get the quran for free
at the dean show dot com yes
yes and for my friend sylvester stallone
i'll go ahead and make myself accessible
to you if you have any questions if you
want some answers to certain things go
ahead have your team hook up with my
team we can go ahead and make that
happen if we can get you on the program
also or just a private conversation
we'll go ahead and make ourselves myself
available for you and other people who
are out there who have some questions
go ahead and call us
1-800-662-4752 get in touch
before some of the haters people out
there have been programmed by much of
the hate and negative propaganda that's
out there go ahead and watch some of our
shows give us a call visit a mosque
and this is the way moving forward so we
can have more peace and harmony in the
world brothers and sisters let's go
ahead and benefit what we started
talking about in the beginning what
sylvester stallone was talking about
time
that kicked us off time
taking advantage of the time we have
left on this earth before
the runway up ahead is gone and we come
to an end subhanallah now go ahead leave
your comments
in the comment section below let us know
what you think you think he'll read the
quran after he gets his message
inshallah with your help go ahead and
like this video help it to get some
traction going so we can go ahead and
get this message to him and others and
don't forget to subscribe hit that
notification bell and support us on our
patreon page jazakallahai assalamu
alaikum peace be with you thank you guys
for tuning in go ahead and watch this
video here
and you can also watch
one of our videos right here you can
support us right here and you can also
subscribe right here thank you for
tuning in to the dean show peace be with
you assalamu alaikum